Democrats really are between a rock and
a hard place here they'd probably like
to dump Biden but For Better or Worse
they're stuck with them right now it's
like buying a box full of air nothing
inside is worth anything but it's all
they got
[Music]
she's exactly right joining me now is
Raymond Arroyo Fox News contributor and
Mike Davis founder and president of the
article 3 project all right Raymond
should the president be primary
well look Jason the presidency is not
Joe Biden's door prize okay and even if
it were he probably wouldn't know which
door to walk through to get it so when a
man has difficulty standing still with a
bicycle when that's a challenge he has
to be primaried to see if he's able
physically mentally and otherwise to
carry out the remainder of the office
that the four years that he's running
for but to just assume because he won
last time that he's entitled to it now
I'm sorry that doesn't pass the smell
test and for the DNC to shut down all
debates and say no no no we're not
having debates we're basically not
having a challenger you better go tell
that to uh RFK Jr who's already polling
in the 20s that's only going to go up as
people continue to see Biden decompose
before their eyes
yeah no that's absolutely right uh
Robert Gibbs revealed Mike how the
Democrats plan to handle Biden's High
disapproval rating have a look at this
as we see us going from that 2022
election into 2024 it is how to take
those soft disapproved numbers
essentially and use that contrast with
Republicans to say even if you
disapprove of the job that currently
that currently Joe Biden is doing when
compared to Republicans for the next
four years you're going to side with a
re-election of the president
all right so Mike the strategy who who
cares if Biden is terrible Republicans
are worse is this really a strategy that
uh they can win you know with back with
President Trump we had peace and
prosperity until Democrats use coved to
shut down our country and BLM riots to
terrorize America you know Trump may
have Mean Tweets from time to time he uh
but I think the American people realize
they made a big mistake by electing Joe
Biden as the President of the United
States
yeah Raymond I got to tell you the
Democrats they are Panic that they could
lose again the New York Magazine New
York Magazine is writing Trump won a
lesser of two evils election and came
very close to winning another Democrats
need to do everything in their power to
make Joe Biden more successful and
popular so Raymond they insist Joe Biden
has a messaging problem as if they need
more cowbell but it's really a policy
problem isn't it rather than more Joe
Biden at the microphone well it's a
policy problem and it's an execution and
communication problem Joe Biden is a
broken and sad vessel let's face it uh
he's broken Faith with his party on the
issues dear to them and he's turned off
the rest of America through his policy
making that didn't end up anywhere near
the campaign promises of unity and
togetherness and healing the soul of the
country which he promised and then
waiting in the wings is Kamala Harris
which is the only thing more or just
more disastrous than Joe Biden so I go
figure that I mean I just pulled her
poll numbers on on 538 she's at 51
disapproval numbers the highest
disapproval rating of any VP ever and
this is a woman who can't explain
Science and Space to you know middle
graders she's got a problem and she has
no constituency so when that's in the
wings Joe Biden's their only option
they're going to push him until they can
push him no more
yeah Mike I remember when Kamala Harris
dropped out of the race I think she was
pulling in eighth place in her home
state of California that's when she
exited the race that's that's where she
was at and and nobody nobody thinks that
she is properly prepared to take on the
mantle of the presidency and she'll
never be properly prepared to take on
the mantle of the presidency what is can
anyone name one accomplishment by Kamala
Harris other than getting elected to
office has she accomplished anything in
her life and by the but Joe Biden said
he would only pick a black woman in his
as his vice president and he picked
Kamala Harris who clearly could not be
the president of the United States it
shows Joe Biden's horrific judgment hmm
yeah uh and Raymond you know the other
problem that Joe Biden has he can't even
answer this most simple of questions the
question would be uh how many
grandchildren do you have I don't think
that he could answer that question well
apparently now the White House has made
a policy decision to say the president
only has six grandchildren when in fact
he has seven the the last being Hunter
Biden's love child there's this New York
Times piece and I have to tell you Jason
politics aside you read this story about
this four-year-old child who knows her
grandfather is the president of the
United States her father is his son
she's never met them never had contact
with him but she talks about them the
tragedy the human tragedy and the
psychological scars for this poor baby
breaks your heart on the surface but
when it comes from a man who continually
tells us your children are our children
we are going to ensure the Dignity of
every human person we're going to make
sure that everybody is lifted up he
can't even do it for his own flesh and
blood so it ends up being a
non-political personal tragedy in the
family that now becomes a political
Anvil around his neck as he goes into
this election because the idea that he's
the great family man or the conciliator
who's going to bring unity and love to
everyone that narrative is shot and what
ashamed what a tragedy for the Biden
family but more importantly for this
little girl
yeah the little girl they don't even
want her to have the Biden uh last name
I mean it would it would be in the world
it would be a nice thing and it happens
to be a reflection of a reality they've
already done this paternity test they
know it's actually true and the idea
that there are some government
bureaucrats on the government dime
sitting around having a meeting saying
how should the president answer the
question about how many grandkids does
the president have Jason you know what
it shows it shows the lengths the
president will go to to protect the
misdeeds of his son and to cover them up
and it's not only this poor child that
he had out of wedlock it's many other
misdeeds and those I think will come
tumbling forward in the days ahead so
who knows where Joe Biden goes from here
it's amazing how closely he's holding a
hunter though uh really since since his
own indictment broke out and that plea
deal
yeah Mike final word to you I would say
that Joe Biden has shown himself to be a
monster he's the president of the United
States he could find a way even quietly
to take care of his four-year-old
granddaughter and instead he's going out
of his way to make it more difficult it
seems like this four-year-old
granddaughter is the only Biden who's
not on some corrupt foreign payroll this
is totally shameful by Joe Biden totally
shameful by Joe Biden they should be
ashamed of themselves
yeah well I I agree I agree Raymond Mike
thank you so much and Raymond uh you'll
be in this seat on Wednesday uh guest
hosting for Laura Ingram we'll see on
Wednesday hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else